Chris Sims pro football talk.com co-host
bleacher report NFL analyst former NFL
quarterback let's start with last night
did you just say bleacher report NFL
analyst yeah I don't work for bleacher
report anymore
what's going on what's going on that's
on me
you know that's all right good I'm glad
it's on you because when I saw any other
damn no no I'm all NBC now but I still
love bleacher report as you guys know I
used to work for them so it's good to be
back on the field program that's I
thought I saw something yes you didn't
did you
it really makes me feel better than it
is on him - yeah I feel good about that
all right
last night's game the new part of the
pass interference rule yeah like what
should the audience know going into this
season about this new rule who I mean
that I think it's gonna slow down the
football game that's that's what I think
they should know I mean you know
ultimately again it was a shame what
happened in the NFC Championship game we
all get that I mean it was you know
borderline criminal what happened to the
Saints and everything but it was one
time in 53 years okay and we now we've
changed the scope of the game we're
gonna have a lot of these moments where
oh let's go back and look who there was
some hand fighting I don't know what's
gonna happen so to me that's the biggest
thing I don't know if there's any you
know underlying factor that this is
gonna be an unintended consequence other
than than I think it'll slow the game
down and it's gonna bore me and it did
last night a few times but and we're
gonna see this all through the preseason
because I think the coaches are gonna be
very aggressive throwing flags to kind
of see how it's handled by the referees
or what they can and can't get away with
after the replay all right let's look at
both sides of the ball here if you're a
defensive coordinator right what are you
telling your defensive backs with this
new rule oh I'm telling them to be
aggressive early I think that's the
biggest thing I think that's the one
thing you hear from just some friends of
mine because they're gonna just test the
limits are we gonna throw a flag every
play what are we gonna do here what can
you get away with you know that the
other thing is if I'm a defensive coach
I really want to get a good feel from
DBS things like that with the offensive
pick plays now that to me offensive pass
interference is something if it happens
10
it's only called once and I think that's
where it could be a dramatically
different year here all the time you
know when you just talk about pick plays
with receivers right the the good
offenses that do it you know the rule is
you're could do it within one yard of
the line of scrimmage when you watch
film and break it down it happens at 3 &
4 yards way too much so that is a big
thing I think to look forward for
because I think defensive coaches are
gonna tell their DVDs hey let me know if
they're doing a lot of these pick plays
and I can be on top of it and keep a
keep an eye on it you know - - I think
offensive pass interference on those
5050 balls more times or not when we
watch I mean go that was a great catch
they do get a good way with a push or
something that the defense doesn't get
away when they do the same type of same
type of thing but what do you think the
if you're a wide receiver how do you
take advantage of this I don't know if
there's anything that I can look at to
go I'm gonna take advantage of this cuz
I would welcome contact if I'm a wide
receiver like I want you to knock me
over you know I like I'd get in your way
because you're gonna be overly
aggressive I want to make you pay for
that over aggression yeah well okay
alright so you're saying in what way
though to make you pay in that over
aggression so what they run them over
you're just saying and then I want like
going for a ball so are you are you
afraid we're gonna see like NBA soccer
style maybe even lops a little bit yes I
think that's a good point Dan I mean I'm
not gonna lie I haven't thought about
that a whole lot but you're right I'm
you're onto something there yeah and it
feels like that we didn't need to get to
this point now my opinion now I'm with
you and and I still go back to if you
have an all-star group calling this
right and I I think you're more nervous
let's say we don't work together but
then we're on a big moment are you gonna
say hey you've made a mistake here the
dumbest thing going on in the NFL right
now don't give me all-star crews right
with different guys that haven't worked
together I want to rephrase that
don't give me all-star referees and then
put together a crew give me the best
crews that's what we should have in the
playoffs here's the crew you know graded
out the best and they're gonna do it
again I'm with you there - there's might
be more communication they're gonna
figure out how the games being played
and I think that somebody would have
said to that official yeah hey we we
messed that up
we need to look at that I think let's
let's huddle and I think that they could
have corrected that in a moment if it
was a regular T and maybe I'm giving you
know that regular team that you know the
familiar with each other and ego doesn't
factor in because this is about were the
best yeah oh you're gonna correct me
right no I know and then you don't know
the guy either and there's no personal
relationship there I'm with you I think
that's a very valid point - you're on
fire here today big guy alrighty Aaron
Rodgers apparently is overrated okay
by who Bucky Brooks put out an article
and said that you know you know I I
guess the performance doesn't match the
adulation here sure well okay I said
Aaron Rodgers is overrated from that
standpoint we've made him out to be the
greatest quarterback of all time yeah
yeah I hear you I know well I've been
fighting this argument for six seven
years when people go what Green Bay is a
Super Bowl contender and I go are you
kidding me have you looked at what's
what because 12 is the quarter but your
first team all Rodgers I am first team
all Rodgers I get that and I understand
what you look at it just from okay the
statistics standpoint and sometimes some
wins and losses and you go oh gosh yeah
okay you know you know me Dan you can't
always just look at the stats and the
wins and then just go oh that tells it
all about the quarterback that's just
not fair
it's not you know yeah he's had games
where his offense as you've heard me say
a million times it's a kindergarten
level offense where I go if you and me
sat down and watched film I go Dan let's
where does he throw the ball the last 10
passes what do you want him to do who's
open what started to do it how did they
get to the point where you have a
brilliant quarterback yes right mine
right and he saddled with Mike McCarthy
yeah how does management allow that to
continue if you have invested in Aaron
Rodgers yes he's the most important
person in the franchise right but I mean
it's a crime what they surrounded him
with it's a it's a sports crime yeah I
mean Dan you know and I know I'm in them
and I know already there yeah I think I
think he's the man Rodgers the greatest
quarterback ever and I do think it's a
crime because of that now with Mike
McCarthy and I'm careful how I say this
because I like Mike McCarthy the head
coach right I like the head coach my
problem was the offensive game plan
designer play call or all of those
things so you know
Rogers a lot like a lot of great players
through history is a little bit of a
victim of his own greatness because we
expect so much every year because he is
the quarterback and it's such a
quarterback league and all we talk about
his quarterback quarterback quarterback
quarterback then the only reason wins or
losses happen anymore the 52 other guys
don't matter anymore
so I mean that that's part of it and
then he's part of some teams right that
I always say this you can go like LeBron
James or you know he was part of some
teams that were there seven and nine
football teams there six and ten
football teams but because he was so
great in some big moments in fourth
quarters they end up ten and six and
then they lose in the first round we go
look he can't win a game when I go well
it's not fair the team's not good
they're only there cuz of him do you
think the Patriots have that much more
talent if I take Brady out of this right
do the Patriots have that much more
talent than the Green Bay Packers have
had in the last ten years mmm
you know that's that's a very broad
question last ten years okay early on in
those ten years if we go back to like
2010 11 12 no I think we're a very fair
battle right around there but I think
once you get to like 14 and on that's
yes I say New England more talented just
a better constructed roster you know
that's the beauty of Bill Belichick
that's why it's very hard to compete
with him but guess what cheque doesn't
get involved in the offense what does he
he does yeah he does he bells bill as
bill is a short list of coaches that
could coach both sides of the ball in
the history of the game he could if they
lost josh mcdaniels bill would be able
to go in there and be the office winner
do it does he have veto power III
believe he does but I mean you know the
one thing I'll say with my years there I
don't know he's probably veto Josh
during the week all ready to go this I
don't like this idea let's scrap this
and you know those are the things that I
really got great joy out of when I was
working there was you know hey I'm
running around doing things you know
it's 7 o'clock at night and there's Bill
and Josh McDaniels talking in the corner
of a hallway and then I go off and do
work and I come back you know an hour
and a half later because I gotta run it
and they're still in the corner talking
about the football and I'm going man
this is a deep conversation so they're
on the same page there and so detailed
and you know New England I know what
you're saying and I don't know what
fight you're trying to lead me into here
either way but I mean New England is
just a different animal and Belichick is
so far above just about any coach in the
history of football and I think I've
told you this before too when I have
friends ask me about what goes on in New
England and how Bill Belichick
approaches everything he does I'm
telling you I don't get a follow up
question because they don't like the
first answer about how hard he works and
he's such a curmudgeon and he has no
life and the things he does I think it
blows their minds to where they go I'm
just gonna stick with what I do and I
don't even go there and that's just what
they're amazing and then you had the top
100 list yeah the NFL Network top 100
right and Drew Brees is the second
player on that list yeah insane and drew
even said that when he joined us
yesterday yeah he said huh
the guy's got six rings is the best
quarterback sure well you know hey that
you know you know what I don't agree
with that totally either but yeah Drew
Brees at number two at this point again
this is an all-time legend you know we
could talk about him being in the
conversation for the greatest
quarterback of all time - or at least
top five with Drew Brees but right now
with the guy who yes I know the stats
look good completion percentage come on
we had three games over less than 180
yards last year they run they're a run
team first that's what they want to do
he you know he was one of the most
Charlie stuff check down quarterbacks
last year intended heir yards I mean
nobody threw it shorter than Drew Brees
he was throwing it shorter than Eli
Manning last year and we all were making
funny like Manning so those are things
you gotta take into account you can't be
the number two player in football when
the coach calls a 40-yard pass and we
got to bring in another quarterback to
throw the ball I'm just sorry that's
where I'll push back against that and I
don't mean to disrespect Drew Brees that
way but hey he's 40 he's still awesome I
get that but to say he's number two I
got to disagree there who should be the
best who should be the number one
quarterback on that list well you know
who I think should be the number one
quarterback but I factor in in Rodgers I
like that Rodgers was injured first game
yes still played right and still put up
unbelief I don't know I know yeah I have
a lot of people that come up to me who
are mad that I made him one in my
rankings right but then they go back and
look at his stats and I go damn I just
forgot he went 26 for two last year
and you know no run game and they fired
their coach you know in week 10 or 11
whatever it was I got a question for ya
before we take a break yeah and I want
you to think about the cool okay you're
the Rams right you got to make a
decision on one guy mm-hmm
you're gonna lose one for the season
okay oh okay you're gonna lose one for
the season Aaron Donald right or Jared
golf save your answer will come back and
your phone calls if you have an NFL
question for Chris Sims eight seven
seven three DP show will continue with
him do you remember that Chris Sims
interviewed you when he was in college
at Texas for a classy head I do on the
air what'd you get Chris Sims from pro
football talk not with bleacher report
joining what did you get in that class I
don't remember I'm not sure I mean I was
always my freshman year I was a very
good student at Texas very good like
Oman I think I got straight A's my
freshman year but then when I realized
the lay of the land and you know what I
could get away with and stuff I just got
by I'm not gonna lie to you there and
you did the interview with me for for a
class on the radio I did yes I I had a
teacher who was very impressed with that
aspect right there that I did that as we
like to say C's get degrees C's get
degrees that should have been tattooed
on my arm all right before the break I
said you're gonna lose one of the two oh
it's a great claret golf or Arron Donald
yeah Erin Donald I guess is the best
player in the NFL he's he's definitely
in that discussion okay there's no doubt
about that
Jared Golf is probably not in your top
10 with quarterback no he's not he's
just he's in the top twenty okay I think
I had him at 19 there so that's it's a
great question I would have say Aaron
Donald without even thinking twice but
there's one little tidbit I think we got
to take into account and I mean you you
might know this a little the fact that
they oblique bortles is their backups
quarterback scares the hell out of me
that scares the hell out of me
so that's what changes the dynamic of
that question just a little bit okay I
mean because I go damn this is a guy
that he's had some trouble throwing the
football he tells everybody he's not a
good thrower the football and he's your
backup quarterback but I still guess I'd
go with Aaron Donald because I'd have
enough faith that McVeigh could make
offense and figure out a new way to make
an offense work with
Blake bortles but Aaron Donald
first-ballot hall-of-famer greatest
interior pass rusher in the history of
the NFL already and I don't say that
lightly cuz I played with Warren Sapp
and he was amazing as an interior pass
rusher but he just wait Aaron Donald's
already yeah I think he is yes I think
he's there yeah
two-time NFL defensive MVP he's
unblockable I mean when I talk to
quarterbacks I even did this on my Chris
Sims on-button podcast I talked to Aaron
Rodgers about the best defensive players
he'd ever played against I mean Aaron
Donald came out of his mouth almost
instantly he's like what he goes every
play is breeze Bri said that he said it
to me yo yeah because every play is
dictated about its breaking the huddle
and go
where's 99 ok I got to fix the
protection this way I got to make sure
this guy's not one-on-one and it just
changes everything and then of course
the trickle-down effect of the matchups
it affects after that is the the big
factor to go along with it all right a
couple of phone calls for Christians Don
and Boston starts us off what's your
question for Chris - Chris thank you for
taking my call sir and you already know
who my pick for the greatest QB ever is
yes I get it you guys I know you aaron
rodgers listed high and I agree his
physical attributes and his talent wise
he should be but don't you agree that he
would be a much better quarterback if he
if he fed into what the coaches were
giving him because I think he bails on
plays too early okay thank you we're
talking about Aaron Ron yeah sure right
and and so we clarify I think he's the
greatest of all time you do you do not
right yeah but I know you respect him
and think he's awesome - yeah that's a
good question
now that this is it's a little bit of a
culture thing there first with Aaron
Rodgers you got to remember it went from
Brett Favre I'm King and to Aaron
Rodgers who we're gonna let you go for a
few years and then like the third year I
was like whoa he's awesome you're king
it's a different culture in Green Bay
altogether you know Aaron Rodgers if I
had to say a flaw about his game what
he's been a little scarred he's had some
some years where and some series of
games where he's dropped back as I be
talked about in commercial break where
he might drop back 30 times and in 27 of
them the first the second and the third
read are not open
so then he's like oh gosh I gotta dance
around and he's not dancing around back
there and doing all that because he just
wants to look cool on TV it's cuz
nobody's open now I do think that
because of some long periods of time
because of that or their games last year
Ryan went oh man just you know take that
five step drop and hit that guy he's
there
but I think he's been a little scarred
there so there are moments like that if
I had to say a weakness to his football
game certainly but at the same time -
it's just a different dynamic it's not
like Aaron Rodgers is some renegade that
was just always like hey fu McCarthy I'm
gonna do what I want to do this do that
no you know it's just a different
culture all together where you know New
England you know who's boss the second
you walk in the door I mean when we talk
about Green Bay Packers the first name
out of our mouth has been Aaron Rodgers
I mean you talk about New England it's
Bill Belichick and Tom Brady and that's
not disrespect to Tom Brady it's just
the greatness of Belichick and what's
been set up there and everything like
that and I get my man Bob the San
Brady's number one I'm not saying that's
a stupid thought trust me I think
Brady's awesome David in Virginia David
your question my question is is as my
Miami Dolphins fan its pours taking
enough from the balichek tree that he
might be successful other dollar check
this I was definitely weren't I love the
fact he fired his offensive line coach
right it looks like he's gonna hold
people accountable down there I know
it's not gonna happen this year but give
him three years you think we get enough
balichek out of him to build a winning
team
I totally do I'm a huge Brian Flores fan
known him for a long time not shocked
that he's already making the team run
when they mess up a fumbled snap or
whatever it is that's Belichick
Belichick Ian in itself not shocked that
he fired the offensive line coach if he
didn't feel right about it he's got guts
he knows what he wants he's tough as
hell he is made to be a head coach and
my big thing with a guy like Brian
Flores I know there's a lot of talk out
there you know Oh New England the
coaches that have come out of there
haven't had great success I get that
first off I think josh mcdaniels will
have great success when given that
opportunity again I was in Denver with
him at that time there was a lot of
things that were messed up in Denver
that people don't know about it but the
one thing I look at with a Flores a
Patricia and even a Josh McDaniels and
some other guys they unlike Charlie Weis
and Romeo Crennel
they were Parcells guys who worked for
Belichick right and the end and these
guys are full Belichick and they started
from the bottom where they like they
know every facet of the organization of
what made us successful from scouting
you know in free agency to the draft and
putting a team together in weekly game
plans and that's where I think these new
crop of New England guys will succeed
more than maybe some of the others that
we've gone well why haven't they done as
well as we thought coming out of New
England all right quick answer here then
we're gonna take a break okay more phone
calls with Chris Sims would you start
Ryan Fitzpatrick or Josh Rosen I
wouldn't be afraid to start Ryan
Fitzpatrick early I'm not shocked if
it's Patrick's in the lead the lead
right now I mean this is a guy that's a
journeyman he's been in this offense a
little before Josh Rosen's young the
second year and it's in a very it's a
tough offense if you don't have a base
about it so Fitzpatrick this team we're
not they're not going the Super Bowl so
if they want to start Fitzpatrick early
and let him take the lumps of the team
kind of getting their feet underneath
them you know they go two and four then
you can see Josh Rosen from there and
see if he's your guy for the future for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]